not many people have asked if I'm okay
but it's it's a very real thing to be
going through behind the scenes for me
I'm sure my wife course is a lot of
stuff for us after a whirlwind year of
adjusting to Parenthood and battling
scathing headlines
Megan Markel and Prince Harry are taking
some extended family time off
et has learned lesbian harassment
there's been sexist racist xenophobic
type coverage it's escalated from Megan
being a breath of fresh air - then
suddenly being deemed vulgar to being
called Duchess difficult to have an
exotic DNA it's gone above and beyond
what royal women normally have to put up
with a royal source tells ET that come
November the sixes will spend some time
with Megan's mom Doria Ragland and split
their time between the US and UK Harry
and Megan are going to be taking about
six weeks off clearly they need some
down family time together and the belief
is that that they are going to be
spending Thanksgiving with Megan's mom
at Doria megan has been very clear that
she wants actually to have a proper
understanding and a connection with
America but it's going to be interesting
to see their approach to spending time
in Los Angeles because of course the
tabloid press follows them there the
paparazzi in particular in Los Angeles
is a vicious nasty beast so they are
effectively trading one set of problems
for another of course Megan and Harry
recently announced they're suing several
British tabloid we need to do is focus
focus on on being real I won't be
bullied into into into playing a game
that's they killed my mom
and they open up about just how
difficult it's been in the new
documentary Harry and Megan in African
journey when I first met my now husband
my friends were really happy because I
was so happy but my British run said to
me
I'm sure he's great
but you shouldn't do it because the
British tabloids will destroy your life
and I very naively I'm American we don't
have that there what are you talking
about that's make any sense I mean
tabloids and get it the sixes might
eventually return to Megan's hometown on
a more permanent basis it's been a lot
of talk of Harry and Megan house hunting
in LA and it actually makes sense to
some degree Megan's mother is her only
blood relative with whom she has a close
loving relationship the reason it makes
sense to buy their own house is because
that way they can implement all the
necessary security I don't think
there'll be house hunting this time
around they'll perhaps rent somewhere
they've got to sort of figure out how
much time they'll be spending here what
their royal schedule allows them to do
in terms of America the costs may
outweigh the benefits of having a house
here but I think it's definitely
something that long-term they would love
to have a base here simply so that art
she has an American home to come to as
well but for now it'll be a quick trip
for the Royal then it's back to the UK
where our source says making in Harry
are expected to attend the traditional
family Christmas at Sandringham which
will be Archie's first they've got my
baby and I've got my husband and they're
the best
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]